Okay, we finally got into my favorite testing topic, which is random testing.
And random testing just means that test cases are created at least in part
using input from a random number generator.
This became my favorite testing method a few years ago, when I noticed though without even
realizing it, I've written a random tester for every piece of software I ever wrote
where I actually cared about its correctness.
So, I've written at least a dozen random testers.
So, let's look at how this works. We have a random case generator.
The test case generator takes its input pseudorandom numbers,
so PRNG here stands for pseudorandom number generator.
Of course, on computers, we almost never get real random number generators.
What we rather get are pseudorandom numbers which are algorithmically generated
but for purposes of creating test cases, they're good enough.
The nice thing about pseudorandom numbers is they're repeatable.
So, when we start using a pseudorandom number generator, we give it a seed
which completely determines the sequence of random numbers it's going to generate.
So, if we ever want to generate the same random numbers, all we have to do is remember the seed.
This is actually nice because we don't have to save of voluminous random tests.
We can rather just remember what seed we started with
if we ever wanted to get back a particular set of random tests.
The other thing that goes into a random test case generator,
usually to make a good one, you needed a significant amount of domain knowledge.
By domain knowledge, I just mean that you have to understand
some properties of the software under test.
We're talking about quite a bit of detail about what form this domain knowledge might take
and how you encode this as part of the random test case generator.
Generated test cases come out of the random case generator
and they go into the software under test.
The software under test executes and produces some output.
The output is inspected by a test oracle.
The oracle, as we've already learned, makes a determination
whether the output of the software under test is either good or bad.
If the output is good--that is to say, if it passes whatever checks we have,
we just go back and do it again.
On the other hand, if it the output is not okay, we save the test case somewhere for later inspection
and we go back and do more random testing.
And so, the key to making this all work is, wrap the entire random testing tool chain
and some sort of a driver script which runs it automatically.
What we do is we start the random tester on some otherwise unused machine
and we go and do other things or we go home.
And while we're doing other things, the random testing loop executes
hundreds, thousands, or millions of times.
The next time we feel like seeing what's going on, maybe coming to work in the morning
and we basically just see what kind of test cases have been saved.
If anything interesting turned out, we have some followup work to do,
like creating reportable test case and debugging.
If nothing interesting happened, then that's good.
We didn't introduce any new bugs and we can rebuild
the latest version of a software under test and start the testing loop again.
Generally, the way random testing works is, is not necessarily part of the test suite
for the software under test, but rather it's a separate testing loop that gets run independently,
acts to the separate or an external quality assurance mechanism.
If the random test generator is well done, and if we give us a sufficient amount of CPU resources
to the testing loop, and if it's not finding any problems, random testing can significantly increase
our confidence that the software under test is working as intended.
And it turns out that in general, there are only a couple of things that are hard about making this work.
First of all, it can be tricky to come up with a good random test case generator,
and second, they can be tricky to come up with good oracle.
And of course, we've already said that these are the hard things about testing in general,
making test cases, and determining if outputs are correct.
Basically, the same thing is the case here, but the character of the problems that we run into
while doing random testing are a little bit different and that's where we're going to spend
the next several units of this course looking at.
What I'd like to do now is go over a couple of real examples.
One of them involves a very large random tester testing quite complicated pieces of software.
The other one is almost trivial, it's a tiny almost one line random tester.
This testing a small function, by the way, so let's take a look at this.